Hey
[Applause]
[Music]
well um thank you so much Carly I just
feel really lucky lucky lucky lucky I
just feel so lucky he gave me the award
I really am so excited to receive this
award tonight because I heard that there
was a significant cash prize Wow it's
not I am mildly excited to receive this
award tonight because I very recently
discovered there may not be a cash prize
thank you to all the people in the UK I
really think that you have excellent
taste except when it comes to desserts
because when you have a dish called
spotted dick a girl has certain
expectations
speaking of dicks
I never once put out to get this award
I wanted to but those no takers
in all seriousness though I'd like to
dedicate this award to a woman who I
think is really great my mother when I
told her that I wanted to be come an
actress she cried in a really sad way
and then she told me that I would never
make it she said our dogs funnier than
you that [ __ ] at least like I've never
pooped on the stage I've actually been
very lucky back in the kinder to be in
some great movies now and I'm also
getting a TV show yeah that is ok
starring the lovely Kevin Bishop he's
here it's called super fun night and and
it'll be out later this year it's a
really good way for me to pass off my
embarrassing real-life stories as
fiction for example the time in one of
my boobs got stuck in a fence so look
out for that
thank you so much to Glamour and anti
Joe and the readers for this award
I will actually soon be appearing on the
cover of Glamour which is a big step up
from my full spread in nuts
I sincerely hope that winning this award
will open some doors for me in the
British industry in particular I really
want to play Annie on the West End I'm
willing to dye my hair red even on my
head
ladies and gentlemen seriously thank you
so much for having me I'm really honored
and completely shit-faced thank you
[Applause]